أجنبي
هذه المرة ، لكنه يحتاج إلى أن يكون دائمًا في
حالة تأهب. القوات الروسية بالقرب من
هذا الموقع على الحافة الشمالية من
منطقة الصقور لم تشهد الكثير من
الإجراءات في الآونة الأخيرة ، لكن الرجال هنا
رأوا الكثير في مكان آخر
في يناير.
حفرة في دونباس
من الصباح الباكر كانوا
يقصفوننا بالمدفعية
وبعد ذلك مباشرة سيحاول المشاة
اتخاذ مواقعنا ويتذكر أنه كان بإمكانك
رؤيتهم في
الكثير من المنطقة الواقعة جنوب هنا ، حيث شهدت
قتالًا شرسًا في سبتمبر الماضي
القوات الأوكرانية هزمت الروس كثيرًا  من
منطقة خادكي
قبل انسحابهم أطاحوا
برج الاتصالات هذا الذي يعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية ، حيث أحرقوا
الأرض تكتيكهم المفضل ،
هذا الموقع الذي تديره
الكتيبة 209 التابعة للجيش الأوكراني ، اللواء 113 في الجيش الأوكراني ،
يحافظ على دفاع ثابت وليس
هجومًا هو أمر اليوم الذي
كان فيه أليكسي فيزيائيًا نوويًا  قبل
الحصول على سلاح ، لدينا ما يكفي من
الذخيرة ، لدينا ما يكفي من الأسلحة
ومعدات دروع مختلفة ، لكن كل ذلك
للأسلحة الدفاعية للهجوم المضاد ،
سيكون أفضل لأن Sony حررنا
الأسلحة التي بحوزتنا بالكاد هي
أحدث الأسلحة التي أظهرتها لنا القوات
قاذفة صواريخ سويدي الصنع عديمة الارتداد يعود تاريخها
إلى عام 1978.
إنهم يدافعون عن مواقعهم بأساليب أخرى
عمرها عقود. وراء هذا
الأسلاك الشائكة على الجانب الآخر توجد
ألغام أرضية
لحسن الحظ هذه المنطقة هادئة نسبيًا
وهي فترة راحة مرحب بها لهذه
القوات التي تعاني من آثار المعارك التي كانت فيها.
كوابيس كيف يصف يفغون
المعركة في الشتاء في دونباس ،
سأتذكرها لبقية حياتي ،
خدم فيتاليس البالغ من العمر 52 عامًا مع الروس
في الجيش السوفيتي ، لقد قطعت هذه الحرب
العلاقات القديمة التي
أكلناها من نفس القدر الذي يقول إنه
يستعيد ذكرياته  أيامه كمجنّد شاب
كان ذلك الحين بعد
معارك كثيرة يستعدون للأم القادمة